this is a production of cornell
university
okay so i'm going to be talking about
our our diploid and triploid cultivar
trials that we've been doing these past
two years if you were here last year
then you got to see
year one in the field and then this is
our our year two trial in these first
two rows uh here
so let's just kind of go over some
basics what is the difference between a
diploid
hemp cultivar and a triploid hemp
cultivar well it's the number of sets of
chromosomes that the plant has so so
most hemp just like humans has two sets
of chromosomes one that they get from
their pollen parent from their dad and
one that they get from their seed parent
from their mom but there's kind of some
some fancy
chemical manipulation that we can do
that we can
make
a different number of chromosomes in the
plant
so this is something that oregon cbd did
if you look at the handout which you can
find on the qr code on
the agenda for the day
you can see that what they did is they
they treated some of their individuals
with a chemical called colchicine which
doubles the number of chromosomes
so instead of being a diploid two sets
of chromosomes they become a tetraploid
four sets of chromosomes and then when
you cross a tetraploid 4x with a diploid
2x you get a triploid 3x
does that make sense to everyone you're
tracking perfectly great uh so so the
next question why would we even want
triploids like what is is the value of
triploids and i'm going to give you a
hint uh things like seedless watermelon
and bananas are also triploid
naturally or man-made and the benefit in
some species of being triploid is that
they do not usually produce viable seeds
so when seeds are produced in the plant
the plant needs to divide up the
chromosomes into different seeds that
then get pollinated by pollen but you
can imagine that dividing three sets of
chromosomes does not go as well as
dividing two or four because three
doesn't divide evenly
so it's much harder for these plants to
make seed and often the triploids are
seedless are sterile
so people were interested in this from a
hemp perspective because if you're
producing cannabinoids you want
unpollinated female inflorescences so
pollen management is something that a
lot of growers have to deal with
something that drives people to do
indoor cultivation
to really need to to manage the
production of
males in their field and also
grain and fiber production in a several
mile radius because hemp and cannabis is
wind pollinated and that pollen can
travel really great distances
so the idea was that if we could have
these triploid cultivars they would be
seedless you could grow them without the
fear of pollination and to test that us
along with our colleagues at north
carolina state and the university of
kentucky decided to do a trial where we
planted these diploid and triploid
cultivars at sites that were pollen free
and also sites that were pollen
challenged so this is our pollen
challenge site you can see our grain and
fiber planting right behind it there's a
ton of pollen there so if these plants
were going to get pollinated we're
giving them the the best opportunity to
get pollinated here
so we're interested in comparing the
diploid and triploid cultivars at our
pollinated and pollen free sites and if
you look on our handout
i'm presenting some of the data from our
sites last year
really really exciting and interesting
data
so the diploids produce seed as expected
interestingly the triploids also
produced some seed dramatically less
seed but some seed still
so as a proportion of the total biomass
our diploids produced you know 40 or 50
percent of the total biomass with seed
whereas our triploids it was generally
less than 10 percent as low as one
percent even in a pollinated environment
so a pretty dramatic reduction in in
seed and that also corresponds with um
the the cannabinoid measurements so we
measured cannabinoids at three weeks
after the initiation of flowering five
weeks after the initiation of flowering
it also bulk stripped floral biomass and
for our diploid varieties we saw
significant reductions in cannabinoid
content at our pollinated sites so more
seed less cannabinoids probably a
combination of things like the the total
biomass being diluted by seed biomass
which is very low in cannabinoids
because the cannabinoids are not
produced in the seeds but if we look at
our triploids at our pollinated and
pollen free environments they produced
about the same amount of cannabinoids so
we didn't see that dilution effect even
though there was a little bit of seed
production
so
i think that's all i really want to say
you can see more on the handout and i
would be happy to take any questions or
we can walk around for a minute or two
before we have to go to luis and jamie's
talk right across the street here larry
has a question why are those plants so
small oh that's a great question larry
the the question from larry is why are
those plants so small if you were here
last year you may remember that the
plants were much bigger last year and
this was because
um
so these are these are transplanted hemp
plants so we grew them in the greenhouse
and you know you grow them in the
greenhouse with the anticipation that
your field is going to be ready when the
plants are ready in the greenhouse
unfortunately we had a very wet june and
this field did not have plastic it was
not plowed up we couldn't get the
tractors in here so we weren't able to
transplant that initial set of plants
that would have been you know probably
this big by now so what we did is we
planted a second round of seedlings
which were delayed about a month and
these are those so they're significantly
smaller than than one would expect but
we should be able to get still good data
off of them uh even though the plants
are smaller
any other questions yes tyler yeah i'm
just curious are all of these plants
triploids out here that we're going to
look at or do you have some comparison
like anyway
that's a great great question tyler um
so tyler asks if all of the plants are
diploi or all the plants are triploid or
if there's there's mixtures so the
diploid triploid trial is actually just
a very small portion of this field we
have a lot of other exciting stuff that
i don't get to talk about in the rest of
the field so these first two rows are
the diploid triploid trial and we have
three uh pairs of diploid and triploid
cultivars so three diploids and three
triploids and they're replicated in five
plant plots four times so there are both
diploids and triploids in the field yes
um
any other questions yes
what um what's the effect of the triplet
on the vegetative growth or other
aspects of the plant growth that's a
great question so the question was
does the being triploid compare to being
diploid
increase maybe the biomass or the
concentration of cannabinoids
so based on the data from last year i
don't think we saw evidence of that um
you know
in the in the pollinated trials
obviously the diploids produced seed and
the triploids did not um so there was a
difference in concentration there but
overall i don't think we see an effect
of triploids being you know larger than
diploids or producing 50 more
cannabinoids in an unpollinated field
yes tyler
have you worked at all you've mentioned
tetraploids as well have you tried to
grow out any tetraplasty
so tyler's asking if we have grown any
tetraploids here um and to my knowledge
we have not grown any tetraploids here
that would be really interesting to do
but our our lab has not gotten into the
whole
culture scene chromosome doubling deal
we're mostly relying on other uh people
who have done that work
and we're just evaluating those
already um so we got
it is a good question though
uh whether triploidy and fiberhemp for
example
might increase the yield
you would have to create it as a f1
hybrid obviously because it wouldn't
make any seed but you have to plant it
as a clone then no
no you you would cross a diploid with a
tetraploid
uh and that would create the triploid
seed and then you just take that seed
and plant that seed but
obviously those plants are then sterile
so you have to do that hybrid cross
every year to make that seed
potentially
yeah so that's a great point that
larry's making about there could be
applications for triploids in other
market classes of hemp including
fiberhemp
depending on what the effect of the
extra set of chromosomes does on the
other traits in the plants and the
possible benefit for fiber would be what
often triploids show increased yield
they're bigger than diploids
so we've done a lot of work on willow
most of our commercial willow cultivars
which are for biomass production are
triploids
is there any work on hybrid bigger with
him
uh so the question was is there any work
on hybrid vigor for hemp so just a
background for those of you unfamiliar
with hybrid vigor
in other crops the canonical system used
to make hybrids as you generate two
inbred lines i'll just use corn as an
example so you can
take two
uh
very different corn lines you can self
them until they're very inbred and then
you can use them to make a hybrid and
then that hybrid shows hybrid vigor or
heterosis so the progeny performed much
better than both of the parents
so this is much more challenging to do
in hemp because hemp is generally out
crossing if it's dioecious it's an
obligate outcrosser so it's much harder
to make inbred lines
there is some work on it from groups
like oregon cbd also our
group published a paper
last year looking at um different hybrid
families of hemp
all across to a single common parent and
how those different hybrids performed
so there definitely is
uh work on it but it is more challenging
in a diocese species than a normal
selfing species
yep are you noticing any differences in
the flower structure when you increase
poisoning
uh so the question was are there any
differences in flower structure with an
increase in ploydy
i
personally have have not noticed that
but that's also anecdotal i don't know
if people have um done
you know inflorescence architecture
quantification and done proper
statistics to test that hypothesis but
it would be definitely an interesting
hypothesis to
test they do flower later oh right
um so so in these these diploid triploid
comparisons we do see that the triploids
generally flower later um which could be
an effect of being triploid it also
could be effects of flowering time genes
that are segregating in these
populations so when oregon cbd makes
their
their hybrids they use an autoflower
parent as their pollen parent so they
can
well for a variety of reasons but um
that is uh one of the the things that is
just innately part of all of their
hybrids um
so in in diploids um the hybrids have
one dose out of two from that auto
flower parent but in
triploids it's one dose out of three so
if this flowering time is is dosage
dependent it could be an effect of the
the genes in addition to the ploidy
alrighty i think we're running out of
time here but um
um i'll be around if anybody has any
questions and i'm excited to hear what
luis and jamie have to talk about at the
next stop
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu